stephen king se veut rassurant le
vocabulaire c'est comme le pénis comme
le disait la [ __ ] au matelot intimider
l'important c'est parce que tu as mon
chou mais comment tu t'en sers je ne
suis pas un grand fan de stephen king
je n'ai probablement lui qu'un ou deux
de ses livres à l'adolescence et je ne
me souviens même plus lesquelles mais
l'on m'a chaudement recommandé ce livre
écriture mémoire d'un métier dans lequel
le célèbre maître du thriller réfléchir
au sens profond de la création
littéraire et donne des recettes aux
lecteurs pour qu'ils puissent s'y mettre
lui aussi j'en ai tiré dix règles grâce
auquel vous pourrez écrire comme stephen
king je suis romain et vous êtes sur
mille idées de culture générale
stephen king a commencé à écrire et à
soumettre des textes des éditeurs très
tôt dès l'enfance en fait bien
évidemment il a beaucoup reçu de refus
avant de finalement percé il en palais
les lettres de refus sur un clou dans sa
chambre est assez rapidement comme il
continuait d'écrire il a eu besoin de
cloud plus long mais il a persévéré
il a beaucoup travaillé pour progresser
en particulier il était très régulier et
il faut écrire chaque jour lui stephen
king se donne pour objectif 10 pages
quotidiennes c'est à dire environ 2000
bon même si c'est devenu de plus en plus
difficile depuis qu'il a arrêté de fumer
et aussi parce qu'il prend de l'âge il
est tellement régulier qu'il ne fait
strictement aucune exception dans les
interviews il se fait un peu passé pour
l'américain moyen qui de travail dit le
week-end ni les jours fériés et qui
prend des vacances mais il ment un peu
comme le bon élève qui n'assume pas sa
rigueur de travail et qu'il l'a fait
passer pour du talent aux débutants
stephen king et conseille d'essayer
d'écrire mille mots par jour et
éventuellement de prendre un jour de
repos par semaine et pour être aussi
régulier
il faut travailler dans certaines
conditions
c'est une règle très connu on nous l'a
répété depuis l'enfance notamment à
l'école est aujourd'hui le milieu des
start up et plus globalement des
entrepreneurs fantasme dessus ils
appellent ça le focus cette règle c'est
tout simplement qu'il faut miser sur la
concentration
c'est vraiment crucial pour écrire
efficacement afin d'atteindre une
concentration maximum stephen king et
s'isole de manière radicale dans une
caisse et dans un bureau dédié à
l'écriture c'est la règle de la porte
fermée pour se couper encore plus du
monde extérieur
il met du hard rock surtout ac dc
guns'n'roses ou metallica à plein volume
pas de distractions pas de téléphone pas
d'internet non plus j'imagine pas
interruption intempestive
donc en théorie personne ne peut le
déranger mais bon stephen king tolère
quand même que sa femme le dérange
on passe maintenant à des règles
d'écriture plus technique
ce qu'il appelle la boîte à outils de
l'écrivain
la grammaire c'est synonyme de calvaire
pour beaucoup de gens mais c'est
impossible de faire sans parce que le
non-respect de la grammaire se traduit
par de la confusion et des incohérences
mais bon stephen king nous rassure quand
même déjà on sous estime notre maîtrise
de la grammaire
on est généralement moins mauvais qu'on
ne le croit et puis on sous-estimé aussi
notre capacité à intégrer la grammaire
alors que la conversation et la lecture
suffisent amplement
bref respecter la grammaire et n'en fait
pas tout un plat règles plus précises
mais tout de même partagé par pas mal
d'écrivains la voix active est
préférable à la voix passive par exemple
plutôt que d'écrire la réunion sera
tenue à cette heure il faut écrire
la réunion aura lieu à 7 heures pour
stephen king le recours à la voix
passive c'est un aveu de faiblesse
selon lui c'est le même manque
d'assurance que celui de l'amant passif
qui n'osent pas prendre l'initiative
bon je ne suis pas totalement certain de
la valeur de la métaphore mais si elle
peut vous aider à vous rappeler d'éviter
la voix passive et bien pourquoi pas
stephen king déteste les adverbes
rarement également admirablement
certainement complètement probablement
stephen king compare les adverbes au
pissenlit un de temps en temps ça n'est
pas trop grave mais si on n'y prête pas
attention on commence à en mettre
partout et là c'est comme une pelouse
recouverte de pissenlit c'est l'horreur
on peut généralement se passer des
adverbes parce que le contexte à lui
seul suffit alors après stephen king
avoue ne pas respecter lui-même cette
règle parce qu'il a souvent peur que le
lecteur ne le comprennent pas en fait le
problème profond que c'est dans quelle
mesure est ce que l'auteur peut compter
sur l'intelligence du lecteur
mais bon la règle simple c'est d'éviter
les à perdre
on considère généralement que c'est la
phrase qui est l'unité littéraire de
base mais pour stephen king c'est le
paragraphe la différence entre les
livres facile et agréable à lire et ceux
qui sont plus difficiles se voient
souvent à ce niveau les premiers
comportent généralement de nombreux
paragraphes courts et beaucoup d'espacés
blancs les second en revanche ont déjà
un aspect rébarbatif et compact avec des
paragraphes interminables et mal séparés
de manière incohérente
alors tout d'abord un livre art est à
risque s'il te plaît s'il te plaît
arrête la critique de la raison pure de
kant donc un livre particulièrement
ardue avec de gros paragraphe compact et
un livre plus simple à lire
qu'est ce qu'une nation d'ernest renan
qui était à l'origine une conférence à
s' est écrit plus gros les paragraphes
sont un peu plus court et c'est une fine
est beaucoup plus agréable à lire le
paragraphe idéal doit être nette et
pratique la première phrase présente le
sujet et les suivantes l'expliquent
c'est donc paradoxalement assez
difficile d'écrire un paragraphe claires
et simples à lire parce que ça demande à
l'écrivain 2
il crée et d'organiser sa pensée pour
citer stephen king un texte et de la
pensée filtré pour autant il est
préférable de ne pas trop penser aux
coupures des paragraphes est plutôt de
les laisser naître naturellement en
conclusion ce que montre ce soin apporté
au paragraphe c'est qu'il faut écrire
pour le lecteur si stephen king et
laisse sa femme le déranger alors même
qu'il suit la règle de la porte fermée
c'est parce qu'elle a un rôle crucial à
l'égard de sa créativité littéraire
c'est bien simple il écrit pourrait
comme ils se sont rencontrés très tôt à
l'université elle l'a suivie et soutenue
pendant toute sa carrière mais surtout
comme elle a une certaine culture et un
goût littéraire l et sa première
lectrice du coup quand il écrit il le
fait toujours avec l'intention précise
et explicite que le produit fini lui
plaisent à elles et ils veulent émouvoir
elle la faire rire elle et il imagine
très précisément ces réactions elle est
donc devenue une pièce fondamentale de
son processus d'écriture il l'appelle sa
lectrice idéal avec des majuscules et
chacun doit avoir un lecteur idéal une
personne réelle ou imaginaire à laquelle
le texte doit plaire en absolue priorité
d'après stephen king tous les livres
d'un écrivain s'adresse sans exception à
son lecteur idéal
il conseille même pour rester motivé
d'imaginer son lecteur idéal en chair et
en os dans la pièce
alors ne vous inquiétez pas il ne s'agit
pas du tout de faire de la télé réalité
du terrain est d'étaler toute votre vie
privée dans vos textes quand stephen
king recommande de dire la vérité ça
concerne l'inspiration littéraire
principalement pour la fiction dans les
cours de création littéraire à
l'université il ne supportait pas la
prétention hippie attiré l'inspiration
du néant d'ailleurs il trouvait la
poésie et la prose qui décès de ce néant
complètement délirante
ensuite il a cru pendant un temps que
son inspiration dépend des de l'alcool
et des diverses drogues qu'ils prenaient
régulièrement mais quand il a arrêté
il a compris que ça n'était pas du tout
ça non l'inspiration n'est simplement de
la vie personnelle
l'écrivain empreinte en grande partie ce
qu'il écrit à la réalité vécue
il ne peut avoir que quelques thèmes de
prédilection mais de sa vie et de ses
réflexions
stephen king reconnaît qu'il est bien
possible d'imaginer totalement ce qu'on
écrit mais ça doit rester marginal sinon
le texte ne sera pas réaliste et n'aura
pas d'impact sur le lecteur non il faut
être attentif à ce qui se passe autour
de soi aux conversations
puis le dire c'est ce à dire la vérité
la philosophie générale d'écriture de
stephen king c'est la simplicité les
règles 4 5 6 et 8 correspondent
évidemment à cette perspective
évitez la voix passive les adverbes
faire des paragraphes clair c'est net
dire la vérité tout ça c'est faire
simple mais la recherche de la
simplicité se manifeste tout
particulièrement dans le vocabulaire
les gens croient souvent qu'un écrivain
a toujours beaucoup de vocabulaire et
qu'il écrit forcément de manière
compliquée or c'est faux
si de grands écrivains sont célèbres
pour la raffinement complexe de leur
style stephen king montre que d'autres
le sont tout autant pour leur style très
direct très simple on pourrait même dire
pur donc n'essayez pas d'utiliser des
mots long ou rares rester plutôt
spontané
prenez le premier mot qui vient à
l'esprit s'il est approprié et expressif
il n'y a pas besoin de faire un effort
conscient pour améliorer son vocabulaire
ça vient tout seul avec des lectures et
avec le temps et encore une fois un
style simple peut être très efficace
stephen king se veut rassurant le
vocabulaire c'est comme le pénis comme
le disait la [ __ ] au matelot intimider
l'important c'est parce que tu as mon
chou mais comment tu t'en sers la
simplicité doit plus globalement m année
de tout le livre comme tout le monde a
quelque chose d'intéressant à dire il
faut être très sélectif de vraiment
garder que le meilleur du texte ôtez mot
par mot phrase par phrase tout ce qui
est inutile
un peu comme pour le montage d'une vidéo
a eu une lettre de refus avait
d'ailleurs donné à stephen king et la
formule suivante version de égale
version 1 - 10 %
tout texte peut être resserrée et il
sera forcément meilleure après pas avare
de métaphores sexuelles
stephen king qualifie le processus de
viagra littéraire
stephen king croit au talent et il nous
prévient que ce n'est pas la peine
d'espérer devenir un génie comme proust
pour autant il est bien possible d'après
lui de devenir un écrivain compétents
voire même un bon écrivain c'est à dire
de mériter être publié et ce qui rend ce
petit miracle possible
c'est le travail il faut se casser le
cul comme il l'écrit à plusieurs
reprises en particulier il faut beaucoup
lire et écrire stephen king conseils aux
débutants de le faire quatre à six
heures par jour
vous devez écrire dans un lieu dédié
portes fermées c'est la règle numéro 2
mais vous pouvez dire partout dès qu'il
ya de la tente et vous pouvez lire par
intermittence une heure par 6 15 minutes
par là tant que vous lisez au total
plusieurs heures par jour
stephen king li 70 à 80 livres par an et
il est beaucoup les livres audio
l'effort de lecture est crucial pour
l'écriture parce qu'il ya un lien intime
entre les deux
pour stephen king c'est tout simplement
impossible de bien écrire sans lire
beaucoup mais il faut aussi écrire
beaucoup issus de la classe moyenne
inférieure de l'amérique ayant été
ouvrier ayant vécu dans une pauvreté
relative avant de connaître le succès
stephen king des fonds donc une éthique
du labeur
écrire c'est une tâche comme une autre
donc il est impossible de bien faire
sans effort et il faut se tenir à
l'objectif quotidien et se casser le cul
si on veut synthétiser les dix règles
d'écriture
elle met surtout l'accent sur la
simplicité le travail et le souci du
lecteur à moi cette recette me semble
vraiment bonne même si l'expérience de
stephen king comporte plusieurs billets
il écrit des romans d'horreur est
fantastique
et puis c'est surtout pour le marché de
masse américain mais bon si vous en êtes
conscient ce livre est plein de bons
conseils pour lire mon article de blog
le concernant ou pour lire ce livre
lui-même tous les liens sont dans la
description
si vous avez aimé la vidéo donnez lui un
pouce bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de
suivante
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser des
commentaires pour recevoir les dernières
idées de culture générale synthétisée
dans le format le plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la
newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site
vous connaissez peut-être déjà aristote
je suis romain et vous étiez sur mille
idées de culture générale rappelez vous
que vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour bien écrire